sus uniformes su simple presencia puede
ser suficiente para causar tensiones
seguimos estos agentes por el centro de
adjunto y una ciudad al oeste de parís
clasificada como sensible por las
autoridades incluso en estas calles
comerciales los policías son a veces del
blanco de los vecinos
esa es la torre de la cebolla es a un
día una persona malintencionada saco las
cebollas de su nevera y nos las lanzó a
nosotros como como explica que la gente
que los repasar arremeta contra ustedes
lanzando las cosas como lo dije antes
nuestra presencia aquí es una molestia
para ciertas personas al patrullar aquí
prevenimos el tráfico de drogas y varias
formas de robo algunos habitantes de la
zona no confían en la policía quítese el
morral vamos a hacer un control de
seguridad me enfurece esto bueno eso no
cambia nada un ambiente tenso
estos jóvenes dicen que le temen a los
controles policiales ustedes hace 14 ó
15 años confían en la policía no mucho
para ser honesto no no consiguió y
cuando nos ven en la calle cuando nos
cruzamos cuál es el problema porque la
desconfianza son soldados políticos
el propio desafío miedo de que nos
rocían con gas pimienta miedo de sentir
dolor lo que escucho siempre es que se
sale de control no pueden negar
eso no es lo que estoy diciendo pero la
violencia policial existe no no digo que
no exista pero no la he presenciado y no
quiero cometer la sobretodo la
desconfianza es recíproca estamos
entrando al sector salvador allende y
los agentes saben que pueden ser
amenazados físicamente cuando se acercan
a ciertos edificios como toma el hecho
de entrar a una zona donde no son
bienvenidos eso hace parte del juego
hace parte del trabajo en general no hay
problemas pero puede haber altercados
sobre todo de noche algunos los
desprecian pero otros los aprecian
especialmente por sus esfuerzos en la
lucha contra la violencia de las
pandillas este hombre estuvo a punto de
morir apuñalado y fue salvado por este
mismo agente volvía de la farmacia si
los policías que me hicieron el
torniquete no hubieran estado allí tal
vez no estaría aquí hablando con ustedes
este es el policía que le hizo el
torniquete
es el sí pero sigue teniendo
sentimientos encontrados hacia la
policía así como buenos policías hay
malos policías
a pesar de la hostilidad de algunos de
los residentes más jóvenes no todo está
perdido
estas conversaciones muestran que se
puede dialogar con los habitantes pero
en el norte de la ciudad el escenario es
diferente en esta vivienda social no se
hacen patrullas y se dialoga con los
habitantes y la batalla entre los
jóvenes y la policía es interminable
un mediador local nos lleva a reunirnos
con algunos de los residentes dicen que
a menudo son intimidados y maltratados
por los agentes y piden permanecer en el
anonimato por miedo a las represalias
utilizan palabras que huelen árabe sucio
tus papás no te enseñaron nada empezaron
a registrarme y hablaban mal mal mal de
los miembros de mi familia como soy
tonto entré en su juego al final su
colega me agarró me puso al lado de él y
me golpeó reconocen que hay agresiones
hacia los policías también aclaró que si
es normal cuando están patrullando y
todos los panas los rodean y no pueden
hacer nada pues nos da risa ver a un
policía en el suelo
solo por saber que esta mañana vinieron
a controlarnos y los para se vengaron
se dan cuenta de que esto es un ciclo
sin fin o sea que lo que está pasando
ahora va a seguir pasando dentro de 10
30 40 años va a seguir así la
desconfianza lleva a veces a la
violencia en un barrio en el que el
resentimiento está a flor de piel para
ustedes no hay ninguna solución si se
sancionará a los policías cada vez que
hacen más su trabajo eso podría cambiar
las cosas pero por el momento una
solución a largo plazo parece todavía
lejana